[Music]
and welcome back to off the record where
we talk about whatever we want
i think we've been talking about food
man what happened we haven't talked
about food oh yeah i'm hungry bro okay i
ate a bag of funyuns and some [ __ ]
what are those things and then somebody
you've been eating all day bro you
haven't eaten all day i feel like it
wasn't enough food for lunch we just had
some boom ball away
it was bomb though i was like super full
is vietnamese food better than the north
or the south do you think
depends who you ask that's that's that's
subjective really i haven't gone to
hanoi i think the northeast i went was
wait which more north da nang or nat
trang
uh
in the middle central vietnam the next
northern more north then
they're both coastal cities i know but
anyways i'm not sure that's the furthest
notice i went and i really want to go to
hanoi i know he's dope oh man i heard
it's different it's super dope what's
dope about it
um well right next to hanoi is also
halong bay so i'm sure you guys like
heard of halong bay which is like that
more infamous like you'll see um like
avatar was like shot and built around
those like
floating island looking places and stuff
like that where like the ships kind of
go out yeah there's like extreme tourism
there now so even if you like go out to
the bay even though it's beautiful
you'll see like trash everywhere in the
water
that sucks but it's still beautiful as
[ __ ] um just don't look at the trash
look up yeah yeah and then that's right
next to hanoi and uh what is cool in
hanoi other than like the
the food the culture and all that stuff
is like during um so i know all of us
[ __ ] love cafes right
condensed milk ice french pressed coffee
right
uh during wartime uh the northern
vietnamese people were doing that but
they were also doing it with like egg
white oh yeah egg drop coffee yeah
frothy yeah yeah it's just a totally
same thing it's also kind of like a
savory-ish type of coffee is it better
that way so it's like a salted caramel
yeah it's just it's just unique it's
more of an experiential thing it's good
protein or unless you were like in your
mind you're like freezing during the war
and like that's all you had maybe you
built a relationship with it you know to
me it's like um
it's not liquidy
it's very frothy oh so the whole thing
is like a froth instead of it being like
uh what we're used to like drinking
oh
it's like a smoothie froth it's like a
moose almost or like yeah it's like a
moose yeah it's it's thick
maybe also just hearing the like
backstory about like what what
popularized it also gave uh some sort of
extra something i think if i were to
just request a regular coffee vietnamese
coffee versus that one i would always go
for the regular vietnamese coffee but
when you're there you just want to
partake
in a different culture yeah did they do
that here is there any place that does
that here it's called egg drop coffee
they dropped coffee yeah do they tell
you the back story no they better every
time they bring it out
well i think that that was more popular
as with the uh northern army so out here
i don't think you're gonna get that back
story i see don't talk about the north
out here man yeah bro that's just touchy
that shall get you killed bro
i remember does anybody remember
probably
mid 90s the protests that were going on
um when that one dude outside of like a
v video or visa i remember that puts up
a communist northern northern vietnamese
flag right and then suddenly there are
just giant protests and riots and
thousands of vietnamese people were
swarming in the parking lot of this dude
like
i saw a toyota camry painted as the
vietnamese flag with three red stripes
right and on top of that they have flag
poles so it was a toyota it was the
whole car was a
was the vietnamese flag and then they
had flagpoles on the side like they were
going into war the three stripes out
here is fine that's the south vietnamese
flag but i mean they were they were
going
like marching for that oh for that yeah
and then they had another truck they had
a [ __ ] truck with speakers and
posters and the whole time they were
going down
remember that [ __ ] dad ow i don't know
what that means but they kept saying
that it's like that awkward or something
like that yeah what does that mean i
don't remember you got out
my suck my dick naught yeah
that's actually the direct translation
at the same time though for the dudes
putting up like a northern communist
fight it's like you're in an area called
saigon right which is like the old name
for the capital for the free capital of
vietnam he's not like i like a vietnam
they changed it after the war one
northern side one to ho chi minh city
what a slap in the face
i mean they changed it from saigon to ho
chi minh city that's usually what
happens in all questions
yeah right but i just remember the first
time i was like maybe 1997 i went back
to vietnam with my with my mom and i
remember we're in ho chi minh city and
i'm like isn't this saigon she's like
don't say that don't say that and if you
want to live
[Laughter]
come with me if you want to survive dude
that sounds just like andy's mom right
that's crazy it's just all deep and
stuff
you know we're used to this coffee the
condensed milk and whatever right like
they they do it the same way but there's
the coffee culture was like just as
crazy as like like european coffee like
espresso like they have so many
different kinds like they mix it with
like coconut or like the weasel poo
or like the weasel poo coffee they're
actually kind of fire coffee yeah it's
actually real good it's actually good
yeah it's pretty good what's good about
it like it just you know came from an
animal's butt that's why it's even
better it's because like the the weasel
will eat the coffee grind and because it
goes through their intestinal tract like
the different types of like toxins or
whatever acid tastes like what is it
it's smoother it's smoother it's smooth
it doesn't have that it's like cold brew
burn yeah better just get cold
nah bro you want the experience because
there's some ideas really hold on let's
eat some coffee beans and experiment
real quick yeah just try it out i'll be
your game you want human poo coffee yeah
let's try it but i mean even the idea of
the coffee culture being like european i
mean
it's french yeah it's french but then
they evolved it to their own style and
then um i was learning about how
okay so most of our coffee is made by
aribica beans so most of our yeah they
don't use robusta but everything out
there is robusta and that's why
vietnamese coffee is like it it's this
strong bolder yeah it's stronger bitter
and it tastes different
oh i love it dance milk in it i love
robusta yeah it tastes way different
it's aggressive you got to get that that
orange tin cafe dumont
[ __ ] little coffee thing with the
with the old asian dude on the like the
[ __ ] cloud that's got the yeah yeah
i have one of those long longs here or
something like that and you can never
get a clean pour like when you pour the
condensed milk when you're going like
this it's always a [ __ ] string and
you're like but when you go to like the
old old vietnamese ladies at the spots
that do it they're like taking out the
can real quick they're going like
favorite company it's a vietnamese one
and um it's like the same color as the
cafe dumont camp right it's like that
weird orange yellow
but it's a picture of a grass hut
that's it's a [ __ ] grass what are you
talking about and i [ __ ] you not this
whole thing you get for like less than
two bucks it's like a dollar sixty-eight
where do you get this out good man ah 99
ranch or something so any asian market
any asian market yeah you'll see it
right next to and cafe dumont will be
like four bucks this [ __ ] will
be like a dollar sixty it's cheaper it's
the dip baby and cafe du monde is
actually not robusta beans oh what is
what is robusta yes
you could tell because when you [ __ ]
pop it open it smells like dirt does it
smell really nice
robust that's why you're the hubspot
robust that's the video that's the only
robot robust
yeah but from now on i just i like that
i don't i don't i don't know i don't
[ __ ] with anything else
yeah it's good dude
do you guys have other like regional
preferences in a particular cuisine
where it's like very very either notable
or common so like taiwanese food is kind
of like rehashed northern chinese food
like similar stuff right like like
[ __ ] like beef noodle soup or shalom
bao that kind of stuff
but that subtle difference i do like the
taiwanese version i don't know what it
is maybe i grew up used to sweeter
and a little bit lighter too a little
lighter and sweeter similar to like the
hong kong way but hong kong's even more
fat and more sweet yeah the beef noodle
soup
just in general the the entire cuisine
in general it's like
like chinese uh food is what known to be
they always gotta add sugar
yeah you always gotta add sugar and
stuff well that's what i'm saying with
taiwan hong kong it seems like there's
even more sugar
more sweet whether it be in the pork
whether it be in the buns whether it be
in the whatever the [ __ ] even the rice
is more like light and sweet yeah
there's like a taiwanese dry rub that
they like to put on everything like from
uh like the popcorn chicken to whatever
oh it's got that like five spice in it
yeah yeah and it has a little bit of
sugar in it like just a little bit sweet
in there
you know what uh whenever i look at hong
kong food or cantonese food it looks
like they like glossing everything their
food comes out with lots of [ __ ] like
they spray it with [ __ ]
corn syrup or something when you eat it
you look like you just got vaseline on
your mouth that's the grease layer on
top of it that's not gonna drink tea
with it bro
is that what it is it's green
except for the green onions that's why
skin's yellow right everything's yellow
yeah
even the vegetables it's got shine like
yeah like they just poured like
sunscreen on everything it was laminated
snow pea
that's what it looks like i cook all
their vegan and vegetable stuff in like
meat oil
i have vegetarian just vegetables and
they put like pork on it real
vegetarian please yeah you got in order
to get real vegetarian from that you got
to be like i'm buddhist oh
my bad respect respect respect eat meat
but if you're like hey hey i just want
vegetarian uh here's your pork
oh really that's how you do it yeah my
mom went to uh me my went to like a
chinese like soup noodle place
and i was like oh can we get like all
vegetables my mom's vegetarian and since
my mom is vegetarian anytime she eats
any meat product and it's she's not used
to she's gonna have diarrhea like right
away oh so she got her noodles
and she ate it and she was about like a
third of the way down she immediately
had to go diarrhea wow and i looked at
the noodles oh [ __ ] it is all vegetables
and i'm like hey is this like
zero meat products they're like i don't
know the broth is like made out of fish
it's like fish broth oh [ __ ] because
it's not vegetarian you know yeah you
gotta say buddhist vegetarian you're
like oh you don't want vegetables still
cooking it in like the [ __ ] pork
saucer all the oil all the juice there's
still shreds of meat let's sprinkle some
fish flakes on
yeah
but then if you say buddhist vegetables
then they'll go oh
you know the animal no kill okay okay
yeah that would kill
them that's what blew my mind right
because buddhism and all that shit's
been there for a while
and there's a lot of vegetarian
buddhists but then like how come they
don't get it
i don't know because i think you're
being picky
but then if your buddhists still be like
oh i get it why you song grateful man
yeah they don't want your ancestors to
come back and [ __ ] whoop their ass
pretty much they're not gonna believe in
that
you know that's all you gotta say
buddhist is it a very like uh i'm not
trying to be racist here but is it like
you are what you eat because when i look
like hong kong or chinese food i see
like pigs
they just look glossy and [ __ ] and crazy
they're all shiny bruh all yellow right
like from the eggs how's that racist if
you're chinese well because you could
talk [ __ ] every oh
go outside of the yellow color and go to
other places and see if it applies yeah
like i don't know well filipino food is
very brown
they eat a lot of brown stuff yeah brown
uh uh uh rice rice
no the noodles the [ __ ] egg rolls
yeah all like a lot of them is brown
all of it [ __ ] sinigang [ __ ] the
lesson that's true japanese people eat a
lot of rice and udon a lot of fish we
fish so much fish wait are we orange
or red looking red yeah
from about the tuna and [ __ ] he's all
trying to think yeah i was thinking
about this and i was like you know what
this is a dumb argument but as you guys
are listing more i'm like absolutely
right
absolutely not a dumb every japanese guy
i've ever smelled smells like ponzu they
do
yo joe smells like ponzu all the time
dog
this dude smells like ponzu and sake all
the time
i don't even drink and i smell like sake
it's almost too much bro like it smells
like matcha yeah
like dust comes out there a little green
dust yeah
yeah dude this guy lives junebe bro this
guy oh my god
was that your company or something what
else does joe smell like he smells like
pelican
rice cakes rice cakes oh guys i think it
is
well isn't that the argument though is
like you are what you eat because like
if all you're eating is like pork
proteins and stuff your body's like
building the rest of your body on
pig parts basically and so you're like a
chinese guy that looked like a catfish
did you ask you be like hey so uh you
love catfish
now that's just how our hair grows
wait if i grow my hair like this
it's gonna i look like a catfish i could
only grow a fruit man tree eating enough
things like bear yeah i don't i i eat
zero catfish though snowman
it's yeah bear i need some more bears
hairy [ __ ] yeah so i can get some get
some [ __ ] that's right maybe i don't
eat enough hairy animals and you know i
think you know what's crazy also though
too is like my body is growing way more
hair
that i used to not have like i should
not have hair on my kneecap what are you
doing eating a monkey you've been taking
testosterone lately right low-key i wish
but i think i'm going through puberty
again or something oh that's cool i'm
getting more hair on me
all over the place a little bit yeah a
little bit is the hair going into the
still no hair there but like everywhere
else that's my dream that's gonna shave
it i know i don't even shave bro this is
bear i would not i would not be mad if i
woke up and just had no
hair down there at all hell yeah dude
like hair on your asshole's annoying
yeah
i don't groom my front but i shaved my
ass yeah yeah i shave my butthole so you
let the front just grow like braid long
[ __ ] yeah dude
it's like his hair it matches the time i
asked to
what yeah oh she likes it hairy in the
front growing out i feel like i'm with a
like a kid when you [ __ ] trim it too
short oh yeah that's time what's her
perfect length then i get i gotta shave
my [ __ ] though eight inches what's
your perfectly like a four
can i get a four eight
four it's not you got a hair hair salon
for that so it's not tickling her face
when she's giving you a [ __ ]
jesus you got that sharp japanese hair
too so it's like [ __ ] thick and like
pointy yeah we got that fishing string
here man i feel like in ancient times
people go and then just go fishing with
that yeah yeah you know what mom used to
do with her hair i used to get these
like eye infections or like cysts or
some [ __ ] gross i know where does it go
yeah she would take her hair and unplug
it i mean unclog it and it actually
works who would take what my mom would
take her hair and she would like stick
it into my eyes
that's why it kept happening and then
they would uh unclog him i would feel
better like the next day i feel better
but like grow three more in a place like
[ __ ] the hydra i don't know i think
because i was like playing on the ham
like jungle gym and then i would just
rub my eyes after you would always touch
your eyes i had all kinds of [ __ ] i
still always touched my eyes too bro
like infections nah
you just have stronger immune system you
know i just i would my eyes look all red
but i wouldn't get like she's like i
went blind for three weeks but i was
fine like other than that i was also
staring at the sun all the time
i could have made it to you you were
doing all right did y'all play in the
dirt and rub your ice yeah no you did it
you don't believe me take your finger
wipe the urinal in the middle like this
pink eye
have you guys had worms before as a kid
no no
i thought everyone got worm how did you
get worms how many people you knew got
worms back then yeah i knew a lot of
kids in my school had worms and [ __ ] i
knew kids are girls are you talking
about the ones that you could see when
they like go through their belly it's
like your butt your butt itches
tapeworms i told the story before but my
parents put vinegar in my [ __ ] when i
had worms how do you get worms though
like damn and how far up the [ __ ]
what was the apparatus [ __ ] be on all
fours they like douchey with a [ __ ]
like yeah and then my my my parents were
like all right this is gonna hurt and
then i felt the tickle tickles and then
they poured the vinegar in my [ __ ]
and it burned her no to me i don't know
i was really uh to me i liked it
i was a willing kid when it came to
fixing [ __ ] i would go through pain just
to [ __ ] fix it i don't care i never
got scared at the doctors nothing
because i was like i need to heal you
know yeah that [ __ ] i just remember that
[ __ ] being traumatizing though yeah
i was it was itching my butt all night
and i'm all scratching it and [ __ ] but
it was i think um that's how they dealt
with it in japan too wow
because they're like oh yeah kids get
[ __ ] worms all the time it's like
vinegar or rice vinegar how do you
i'm ignorant how do you uh worms in your
[ __ ] yeah i think like you [ __ ]
around with dirty
hands you know and you eat [ __ ] like a
kid you're on a playground whatever
right and then what goes through
yourself it's a parasite oh god you get
pimples in your ass yeah
and your mom actually saw like a worm
yeah that's what they did and i got it
more than once man
so how many times what kind of what kind
of worms is called warriors
and worms i've never seen it but it's
not on your ass no that [ __ ] [ __ ]
tickled and it felt so gross
yeah colonoscopy yeah yo that must be oh
ripped off yeah i'm like itchy already
just they don't like diesels don't like
vinegar look it's acidic it's on the
[ __ ] dude it's on the [ __ ] dookie oh
yeah treatment of pit worm is it is it a
vinegar you're gonna be like go to a
doctor yeah yeah type in vinegar vinegar
like pink one at home remedies don't
listen to asian moms
dude that's probably why i smell like
ponzu my mom [ __ ] made me drink that
[ __ ]
soy sauce and vinegar
ponzu is my favorite honestly ponzu is
like one of my favorite sauces hell yeah
i think ponzu over soy sauce all day
[ __ ] yeah so good you could it's it's
hard to get bored of it it's true
everything yeah i'm not well i'm not
dipping my like sushi in ponzu that's
true
i'll be dipping
sashimi in it yeah no but then when you
get um red snapper they put they brushed
ponzu on it or scallops
we went to a lake japanese friends
we went to a lake in uh utah i forgot it
was like lake mead i forgot what the
name no that's vegas lake
yeah that's my area southwest is my area
now dude yeah yeah my bad nice island
[ __ ] vegas guys
like oh yeah learn about vegas anyway so
i went to uh this lake and they were
saying
as you're going in they're like oh watch
out for swimmer's itch you guys have you
guys heard of that what is that it's a
parasite though it's a parasite in the
water and it hangs out in the shallow
areas and they tell it they tell you
about it
and you're like tripping the whole time
you're about to get in the water because
you're like [ __ ] i don't get
swimmers tell me this [ __ ] after dude
yeah i mean if you if you're going into
shitty still water you're going to get
10 kinds of parasites
you know what scares me have you heard
of that parasite in the amazon that if
you're pissing it like swims it's like a
fish or something that swims up your
piss stream and like gets in your dick
you better have a thick piss tree that's
what i'm saying though like the fact
that they've evolved to be like yeah i'm
gonna make it up this thing that scares
the [ __ ] out of that that's why you need
kegel control so you could pee a little
bit oh so you see it come here you see
it
see it stopped while you're pissing you
just chopped the stream again
yeah yeah swimming him why'd you just
pee in your hand and just toss it out
you need foreskin and before you jump in
you get an ice cube and you shrink your
dick a little bit so it goes like i
don't need an ice cream
i want your mouth
you can't get me i don't need i don't
need no ice to shrimp and not just
a parasite a [ __ ] honest circumcised
dick
[Music]
you